my name is Tomas Lopez and I'm an
attorney - Brennan Center I'm working on
voting rights in elections fees the
Shelby County versus holder was a
Supreme Court case that was decided last
June and a concern section 5 of the
Voting Rights Act the reason section 5
is so important and the reason why the
Voting Rights Act is in place is to make
sure that we don't have this
commendatory voting laws in place now
without section 5 in place any
jurisdiction can proceed with changing
its voting laws without having that
change vetted - the possibility of harm
things are making voting more difficult
in a few different ways they're
requiring strict forms of identification
to vote they're restricting the ability
for people to vote early they're making
it more difficult to register by moving
up deadlines or complicating the process
these unfair laws are really being
pushed by politicians who are trying to
manipulate the system for their own
benefit and while that affects all
voters it does have some much more
directly than others if you're looking
at restrictive laws we're seeing that
they're especially common in those
states that had large black turnout in
the 2008 election large growth in Latino
populations I think we can all agree
that ineligible people shouldn't vote
but I think it's also the case that
people should agree with politicians and
pass laws that keep eligible citizens
from casting their ballots the realities
of these laws do very little to protect
the integrity of elections but they do
actually keep people who happy who are
legally able to vote from participating
in our democracy
you